President Trump attacking Democrats
after a high-stakes hearing on Capitol
Hill Acting Director of National
Intelligence
Joseph McGuire testifying on the
whistleblower complaint after it was
made public the whistleblower accusing
the White House of putting the
transcript of President Trump's call on
a separate computer system mostly used
for classified information
here's chairman Adam Schiff clashing
with the director I don't believe it has
corroborated by other folks the
whistleblower says that he spoke or she
spoke to about a dozen other people this
is second-hand information you made the
decision to withhold it from the
committee for a month
there's no time was there any attempt on
my part sir ever to withhold the
information but would you agree that if
there's a serious incredible an
investigation that you agree there
should be an investigation I believe
that it is a matter to be determined by
the chair and this committee president
Trump responding after the hearing it's
another witch hunt here we go again
it's Adam Schiff and his crew making up
stories the Democrats are going to lose
the election they know it that's why
they're doing it my call was perfect the
president yesterday of Ukraine said
there was no pressure put on him
whatsoever what these guys are doing
Democrats are doing to this country is
it disgrace and it shouldn't be allowed
to Nancy Pelosi has been hijacked by the
radical left and everybody knows it
another moment that's getting a lot of
attention and it's a doozy Adam Schiff
creating controversy after
mischaracterizing Trump's call with the
Ukrainian president I'm gonna say this
only seven times so you better listen
good I want you to make up dirt on my
political opponent understand lots of it
and by the way don't call me again I'll
call you when you've done what I asked
this is in sum and character what the
president was trying to communicate
chef's later claiming it was just a
parody but Greg isn't parity is supposed
to be funny that one wasn't we got a
single shot at Dana really quick that's
what she look like a secret agent from
Candy Land
no you're right so Adam Schiff opens up
by making up past
from this transcript and attributing it
to Trump's voice and when he's caught he
says oh it's a parody these are the same
people that just parse over Trump's
words if the transcript was truly
damaging he wouldn't have needed to make
up anything he truly is full of [ __ ]
about this uh this uh this this
complaint so the media and the Democrats
are embracing secondhand gossip over an
actual transcript they're like twenty
variations of the guy saying I was told
so the media sites as evidence I mean at
the the complaint they cite that's
evidence media right they cite Politico
I guess ABC George Stephanopoulos so
this complaint is a mixture of hearsay
falsehoods media clippings it's
basically the steel dossier less peeing
and more lying but they realized that
they couldn't beat the transcript
because those facts go against their
story finally I want to address the
bombshell that everybody's talking about
the lockdown
the tighter restrictions on the
transcript why would they do that do you
think maybe because two years ago people
were leaking transcripts from the
bleeders to the leaders conversations
with Mexico and Australia so they were
putting this stuff in a separate
codeword system because it was being
leaked doesn't that kind of make sense
especially when Trump releases the
transcript why would you release
something you were hiding it wasn't
about trying to hide something it was
about trying to protect something from
being leaked that is common sense but
when you're when you're flooded with
cognitive bias you can't see the sense
you can only see what you want to
believe especially true like if they
came out and said this is a practice
that we started after that if they were
to say that I think that would certainly
help them on to your point about the
complaint and secondhand knowledge yeah
a lawyer I talked to today Jesse said
this document would be inadmissible in a
court of law because it would be
considered hearsay and that the no judge
would allow it well I read the complaint
and it reads like a thriller novel and
it reads like it was professionally teed
up by a conspiracy inside the White
House trying to destroy the president
before the president destroys them
remember the context about the
bill bar Durham and these investigators
are about to blow up the entire Spygate
cabal they're about to name names and
this whole thing is about to unravel so
before they do this is the intelligence
community again striking back at bill
Barr and Donald Trump this is warfare
now because if you read the complaint
this is stuff that's so detailed and so
comprehensive and so sophisticated and
coming from so many different sources at
so many different levels this has to be
an organized cabal of people inside
selling this guy the bill of goods so
then he gives it to the Democrats
because it reads like a thriller this
doesn't come out of thin air and there's
no guessing why bill Barr is
specifically named in this whistleblower
complaint and it's because they need to
discredit him before this thing is
released and you're gonna hear also
request for him to recuse himself from
not only the Ukraine investigation but
also the Spygate investigation this is
what this is all about this is sick and
it's no coincidence the Adam Schiff is
running this operation again he's been
totally humiliated remember he was on a
phone call trying to get naked pictures
of Donald Trump in a prank phone call
before that was exposed the network's
took this live all day interrupted
regular programming huge mistake the
thing had no energy and remember this
guy Adam Schiff was the one that said he
had proof that there was Russia
collusion and he never produced it now
he's saying he has proof that there is a
quid pro quo he still does not produce
it so now he has to fabricate quotes to
sell this thing to the American people
because he can't sell it on the
substance wantonness the speaker pelosi
she had his press conference at 11:00
a.m. and she flat-out said that the D
and I broke the law the Democrats think
that this was a very good day for them I
think they do think it was a very good
day Dana and I mean they're the reason
they think it's a good day is you know
just just get back to the heart of the
story basically the whistleblower
complaint was backed up by the
transcript released yesterday what the
whistleblower had to say again
confirmed all that was we read yesterday
in the transcript and the idea of the
lockdown
there was no national security issue
here none it's just not about politics
it was about politics that's what they
were protecting and in addition
according to the whistleblower
you have lawyers in the white house who
are saying you know we have several
these conversations that we put into the
secret system they are concerned about
protecting this president from leaking
own political damage and so when you get
to that point you start to wonder what
else is going on in this White House
because I dig anonymous source from the
wash no I'm not I'm sliding that the
width I said the whistleblower okay the
whistleblower who was followed by
someone else correct up everything so er
has said so far has been backed up by
that Judge and then the idea that he was
soliciting interference from a foreign
country for the 20 2011 ask for the
servers for the servers back which is
the game plan isn't it because they were
afraid of Joe Biden they want to
demonize Joe Biden just like that was
the game plan to go after Hillary
Clinton are afraid that Joe Biden is
going to get taken out and that Trump is
going to run against Elizabeth Warren
and that he will win reelection because
at this point they think Joe Biden is
the best person to take him on in swing
states like Pennsylvania Wisconsin but
Michigan etc but one thing I think
that's really important to continue
pointing out I talked to a couple of
people today who deal with whistleblower
complaints from the side of receiving
complaints and and putting on
protections for people who issue these
claims and they said that it is highly
unusual that it claim with second or
third hand knowledge would ever be
considered something that was legitimate
because specifically the law protects
people with first-hand knowledge when
you look at the complaint there are
multiple references to a number of White
House officials who told me X well if
that is the case and if it is so
egregious that it requires executive
privilege to be waived and for the
inspector general and the FBI to get
involved those White House officials
have the protections to present this
information for
sand and the other big thing is that was
detailed today by the Acting DNI chief
is that Congress wouldn't have gotten
the information that they have with the
complaint being released if President
Trump hadn't released the transcript of
the call because it got rid of the
classification and it got rid of the
executive privilege and so the only
reason why Congress got this is because
the president was transparent in doing
an unprecedented move and releasing this
call and that is why the rest of the
country has been able to read this
complaint and to what you said it's not
consistent with what the transcript says
there's a lot in the complaint that
doesn't add up to what the conversation
the reason is not because of Donald
Trump the reason this came out is
because somebody now had the heart had
the strength to say I'm gonna be in the
contest and put my career reestablish in
order to stay on this country can we
establish one fact please in order to
just move the conversation along to
talking about this for a very long time
okay would you concede yes that the
Democrats were suspicious of something
Donald Trump did wrong during the last
election and they used foreign countries
help and foreign assets to help them
investigate Donald Trump in his
associates that's what true you think
fusion GP ever supposed to be a hard
news guy here they better investigate
this stuff so let me get your hard news
hand online yes and company you better
chew on it was more than that it was
also the Obama administration sending
people out overseas to invest